let's talk about Donald Trump's tax
returns briefly the situation with
Donald Trump's tax returns is escalating
to the point where Donald Trump is now
effectively begging the supreme court to
hide his tax returns from investigators
and this is hilarious
but it's also very important in terms of
what is quickly becoming a battle really
about the separation of powers in the
United States and about checks and
balances so I'll catch you up and then
we'll get to the news investigators have
a criminal probe going in to Donald
Trump and his businesses finances
they've tried to obtain Donald Trump's
tax returns and his business tax returns
for this investigation Trump tried to
block it multiple courts have already
okayed it the next step is the Supreme
Court and indeed Donald Trump has filed
for an appeal to the Supreme Court now
what's important with the Supreme Court
is they're not required to take the case
at all they're not required to review
the ruling of the lower court in this
case it's the second district court the
Supreme Court might decide we're not
going to take the case and in that
situation the lower court ruling would
stand which in this particular situation
is a ruling that says Trump has to
provide the tax returns to the
investigators importantly the Supreme
Court currently has two Trump selections
Neil Neil Gorsuch and the absolute
lunatic Brett Kavanaugh the Supreme
Court is going to announce in the next
few weeks if they will review the case
if they agree to review the case that
review probably will happen before the
2020 election now there is breaking news
on this the Supreme Court did yesterday
impose an indefinite delay on the house
of representatives demand for president
Trump's financial records to give them
time to figure out how to handle the
dispute until they decide what is going
to happen with this case that case the
other case related to Donald Trump's
taxes but this is a major separation of
powers case because if the Supreme Court
does take the case and they decide you
know what Trump does not have to turn
over his tax returns what does that say
about our checks and balances the checks
and balances in our system what does it
say about Donald Trump's
ability to or not to have to obey
prevailing laws it also relates to this
issue of Donald Trump's immunity Trump's
lawyers claim that Donald Trump has
immunity
not just from prosecution but even from
investigation that is a very loose
reading of any law that you can find and
a big piece of all of this is going to
come down to that because remember we
were told and even robert muller said at
the conclusion during his testimony and
and in the Moller report that he did not
take a position on whether Donald Trump
should be indicted on obstruction of
justice because it is the policy via
memo it has not been legally tested but
it is the policy via memo of the Justice
Department not to prosecute a sitting
president
that's layer one we could we could argue
that we could debate that there is this
further position that Donald Trump's
lawyers are trying to argue that Donald
Trump's taxes and his business taxes
should not be provided to investigators
in New York why because Donald Trump is
immune even from investigation and I
have read no seriously legal opinion
that agrees with that and then of course
we go back to the bigger picture on the
merits anybody working this hard to hide
their tax returns has something to hide
that is very very serious we don't have
to go through that once again I don't
believe that Donald Trump's taxes would
expose criminality although arguably
double accounting and one set of books
for loan purposes and one set of books
for tax purposes in New York State is
actually against the law I believe the
most likely scenario is that Donald
Trump would be exposed as not being as
wealthy as he claims to be
I believe that Donald Trump's shady
business dealings which are the subject
of much speculation with all sorts of
different countries could be Russia
Saudi Arabia and others would
potentially be exposed and it would be
both personally embarrassing to Trump
and also problematic for him I don't
know that it's a shoo-in that there's
actual criminality or at least
definitive criminality that would be
exposed by Trump's tax returns although
I certainly wouldn't rule it out and it
would
come as a surprise given everything that
has got gone on so my questions to you
number one why do you believe that
Donald Trump has been working so hard
for so long to prevent the release of
his tax returns number two what do you
believe will ultimately happen with this
case and the release of Trump's taxes
will the Supreme Court take the case let
me know what you think remember to get
on the David Pakman show newsletter at
david pakman.com on black friday if you
are on that newsletter you will receive
an email with a very special discount
code useful only on Black Friday for a
major membership discount at the David
Pakman show you need only sign up for
our newsletter at david pakman.com we
will take a quick break I have an
interesting video for you coming up next
we will talk about the schedule for the
show for the rest of the week because
there is a lot going on and a very
interesting voicemail still to play for
you today's program brought to you in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman
blinkie's
is a great service that I use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book BS jobs by David
Graeber which I listen to on bling cos
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about 5 bucks a month that's be Li NK
ist dot-com for
/pa que mas